unbiased news is a myth ground news is a
news comparison platform that empowers
you to see how the political biases of
different sources are influencing the
news you read
download the ground news app for free at
davidpakman.comground
so the big news this weekend of course
was that donald trump was
acquitted in his second impeachment
trial no president has ever been
impeached twice
donald trump has been impeached twice
and now
in both subsequent impeachment trials
remember
the house impeaches the senate tries
trump has been
acquitted in both trials and to convict
on impeachment you need two-thirds
a vote to convict in the senate all 100
senators being present that means that
on saturday
67 senate votes were needed and they got
only
57 that's all 50 democrats
including newly minted democratic
senators
john ossoff and rafael warnock radical
liberal
raphael warnock that guy remember him
that includes the two of them
reminding us uh of the importance of
those january 5th
primaries getting to 50 and then seven
republicans
voting to convict those were richard
burr
bill cassidy susan collins lisa
murkowski mitt romney ben sasse and pat
toomey we will talk about why those
seven
a little bit later but 57 is not 67
simple math tells us that and so donald
trump did end up
acquitted now not a surprise we knew
all along that it would go this way but
one of the really wacky things that
happened is that senate
minority leader no longer majority
leader senate minority leader mitch
mcconnell
voted not guilty and then immediately
took the floor to give a defiant and
detailed speech
about how donald trump did incite
the riot and did incite the violence
and the insurrection and we're going to
look at some clips here
mitch mcconnell moments after voting not
guilty
making as good a case as the house
impeachment managers about donald
trump's guilt
about donald trump's responsibility
about donald trump's culpability for the
insurrection and the riots
that took place on january 6th but he
voted not guilty let's get into it
there's no question none
that president trump is practically
and morally responsible
for provoking the events of the day
no question about it the people who
stormed this building believed
they were acting on the wishes and
instructions
of their president
and having that belief was a
foreseeable consequence
of the growing crescendo of false
statements
conspiracy theories and reckless
hyperbole
which the defeated president kept
shouting into the largest
megaphone on planet
earth the issue
is not only the president's intemperate
language
on january 6.
it is not just his endorsement of
remarks
in which an associate urged quote
trial by combat
it was also the entire manufactured
atmosphere of looming catastrophe
the increasingly wild myths myths
about a reverse landslide election
that was somehow being stolen
some secret coup i i mean
a total and complete indictment of
donald trump's
actions but so why vote not guilty
mitch and here mitch mcconnell explains
if president trump were still in office
i would have carefully considered
whether the house managers
proved their specific charge
by the strict criminal standard
the president's speech probably was not
incitement however
however in the context of impeachment
the senate might have decided this was
acceptable shorthand for the reckless
actions
that preceded the riot
but in this case the question is moot
because former president trump
trump is constitutionally not eligible
for conviction now this is a close
question
no doubt donald trump was
the president when the house voted
though not when the house chose to
deliver the papers
and there is basically the explanation
mcconnell
going on to say that since the
punishment
for impeachment is removal from office
and donald trump is out of office that
this was not a proper
impeachment they cannot convict as a
matter
of procedure is what mitch mcconnell is
arguing now
in saying that mitch mcconnell misses
a number of important details the first
detail is that a week ago today
last monday we had a full day of debate
about whether the trial was okay
and whether the senate had jurisdiction
to try a former president and they voted
and settled that issue 56-44
but mcconnell won't let it go the idea
of how the senate
works is that as a body the senate dealt
with that question
it wasn't unanimous mitch mcconnell was
one of the 44
who believed that the senate did not
have that right but as a body
and again if you want to say how you
know the senate is not a legal body so
why is the senate even voting
on the constitutionality of the
proceedings they chose to
and they decided that yes 56 to 44 they
can do the trial meaning if they
determine the person did what they're
accused of doing
they can say guilty but mcconnell
doesn't care so mcconnell is using an
already adjudicated issue
to say that's why i voted not guilty
second
it's not just removal from office that
is being
debated and voted on and is the
punishment it is also
barring trump from running again a
punishment which could be
met it out but mitch mcconnell chooses
not to mention that and only focus on
removal from office so
a truly pathetic attempt by mitch
mcconnell to play both sides
he gets his not guilty vote in and
appeases the trumpists
he denounces the actions of trump
appeasing the more
sane republicans and on he goes as he
has been doing for year
after year after year uh impeachment
manager madeline dean
noticed how bizarre of a situation it
was
mitch mcconnell voting not guilty and
then speaking
90 about why trump is guilty and then
mentioning but he's out of office so i
had to vote not guilty
take a look at this madeline dean clip
uh it was powerful
to hear the 57 guilties
and then it was puzzling to hear and see
mitch mcconnell stand and say not guilty
and then minutes later stand again and
say he was guilty of
everything history will remember that
statement of speaking out of two sides
of his mouth
now different republican senators have
been citing
different reasons for why they voted not
guilty most of them
some some taking the mitch mcconnell
approach
about procedure others saying trump
didn't really do the incitement
but really it's just political
expediency because when you look at the
republicans who did vote to convict
you start to get a picture of what's
going on here lisa murkowski knows she
doesn't need to be on trump's side
to win in alaska so she's free to do
whatever she wants
ben sasse has never really cared about
party approval
and he's taken hits from the republican
party and he doesn't seem to care so
that's ben sasse cassidy is in louisiana
where there are no
standard party primaries he doesn't have
to worry about that
mitt romney okay after the meeting where
he had the frog's legs
and thought maybe trump would make him
secretary of state after that
romney really hasn't cared and we know
he doesn't need donald trump support
uh in utah because utah republicans are
some of the most anti-trump republicans
in the country
pat toomey and richard burr they're
retiring so they don't care
and then susan collins has this more
moderate constituency
in maine so these aren't coincidences
that
these are the seven republicans
who voted to convict these were not
seven republicans who believed trump was
guilty and 43 who did not
this was probably several dozen
republicans who believe trump was guilty
seven of which seven of whom uh
have particular circumstances that allow
them to actually vote their conscience
rather than what we saw for many
republicans and of course you have
many republicans who genuinely believe
that this was all
you know unnecessary and unfair and all
that i'm guessing
i don't know which ones those are i
guess ted cruz would be one maybe josh
hawley some others so that's that
trump acquitted 57 to 43 a major a
majority saying guilty
but needing that two-thirds vote trump
acquitted and let's now get into some of
the other
interesting moments from the last day of
the trial the last couple of days of the
trial
there were many compelling moments
sprinkled throughout the hours and hours
of presentations
during donald trump's second impeachment
trial
one of the most interesting came during
the portion of the trial
when senators can send up questions to
be answered by either or
both the house impeachment managers and
donald trump's
defense lawyers bernie sanders sent up
a really simple question and it
completely
set off attorney michael van der veen
one of donald trump's attorneys
and the question was simply did trump
lie about winning the election
is it true what the house manager said
which is that for months donald trump
wrongly
claimed to have won the election bernie
asked it
van der veen went nuts asking who asked
that
and a titillating exchange took place so
we'll take a look the question is read
by the clerk but it's bernie's question
that bernie sent up
and when van der veen asks who asked
that you will hear bernie in the
background say i did
and then all hell breaks loose and
counsel for the former president
recognized for two and a half minutes
of course the clerk will read the
question again
the house prosecutors have stated over
and over again
that president trump was perpetrating a
big lie
when he repeatedly claimed that the
election was stolen from him
and that he actually won the election by
a landslide
are the prosecutors right when they
claim that trump was telling a big lie
or in your judgment did trump actually
win the election
the uh council for the former president
have two and a half minutes
my judgment who asked that
my judgment's here relevant in this
proceeding it absolutely is
what's supposed to happen here is the
article of impeachment
the senate will be in order
um the
senators under the rules cannot
challenge the
content of the response the council will
continue
we have the question read again please
the house prosecutors have stated over
and over again
that president trump was perpetrating a
big lie when he repeatedly claimed
that the election was stolen from him
and that he actually won the election by
a landslide
are the prosecutors right when they
claim that trump was telling
a big lie or in your judgment did trump
actually win the election
in my judgment it's irrelevant to the
question before this body
what's relevant in this impeachment
article is were mr trump's
words insightful to the point of
violence
and riot that's the charge
that's the question and the answer is
no so michael van der veen really not
liking bernie's question
but it actually got van der veen to say
something
fascinating you heard van der veen there
say
the only issue here is whether what
trump
said was an incitement to the riots
many of the republicans who voted not
guilty including mitch mcconnell as we
just covered
said trump did incite the riots but
that's not the question
so i i this is not trivial understand
how disjointed and pathetic this
all is trump's own lawyer when asked by
bernie
was trump lying when he said he won the
election says
the only only only thing being
adjudicated here
is did donald trump incite the riots
mitch mcconnell comes in
and says not guilty yes trump incited
the riots
yes what trump did is morally
indefensible yes what trump did was
foreseeable
in leading to what it led to but that's
not the issue the issue is simply
whether we can convict a president
that's already out of office even
trump's own lawyer there says the only
question is whether trump incited the
riot and if yes then presumably you vote
guilty but mitch votes not guilty and
then says trump didn't cite the riot
but it's a procedural explanation for
why
i voted not guilty they aren't even in
agreement
about what this trial was about
now to deal with the other part there
are people who wrote to me
and said it was funny to see vanderveen
triggered by bernie's question
but that factual question isn't actually
relevant to these proceedings now
strictly speaking
it is true that the lawyer's opinion
about a matter like that isn't relevant
to whether trump is or isn't guilty
but remember that this isn't a court of
law this is an impeachment court
in the u.s senate and adhering to the
truth
is relevant much of the case that van
der veen and trump's other lawyers made
didn't adhere to the truth so merely
and and remember it's not a criminal
proceeding senators can ask anything
as a check on the validity and
comprehension of these lawyers
it was interesting to hear bernie asked
such a basic factual question
it's also relevant that in the entire
context
in which trump's actions are being
interpreted in terms of his inciting the
riot
it would be different if in reality
trump had won
trump may i'm not saying that the moral
consideration about the riot would
necessarily be different that would be
for each senator to think about and
judge
and for us if the election really had
been stolen from trump
i think there are tens of millions of
people including many on the left who
would see the entire thing
differently so um an interesting moment
for sure and van der veen just
i mean like instantly hair trigger set
off by bernie's question
let me know your thoughts now that the
impeachment trial is done
what's next i'll talk later about well
one of the things that should be
immediate is coveted relief but send me
your thoughts you can find me on twitter
at deepakman the david pakman show
at davidpakman.com
[Music]
the riots at the capitol made it very
clear that misinformation is one of the
biggest problems that our society faces
and online
filter bubbles make the problem worse
making it difficult even for intelligent
news consumers to figure out what's true
and what's not
one of our sponsors is ground news which
is a platform with a really effective
approach
to combating this problem ground news is
the world's first
news comparison platform that lets you
compare
how sources from across the political
spectrum are covering a story
i use it myself i love it because it
lets me
easily see how different news outlets
are manipulating a story to fit their
own narrative
and it shows you your news blind spots
stories that your side of the political
spectrum
may not be giving attention to start out
2021 with a balanced
news diet download the ground news app
for free
by going to davidpakman.com ground
the link is right underneath this video
[Music]
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
our program is primarily and
uh importantly funded by our audience
listeners to the podcast viewers to the
youtube channel people listening on the
radio watching on free speech tv
i invite you to grab a membership at
joinpacman.com you'll get the daily
members only bonus show
commercial free audio and video streams
of the show and the
satisfaction of knowing that you are
supporting
independent media sign up at
joinpackman.com so we spoke earlier uh
trump's second impeachment trial is over
he's been acquitted exactly as we
predicted
i was expecting five republicans to vote
guilty we got seven
that's something but still not the 67
that we're required to convict
now with impeachment out of the way and
not that this should have delayed
coveted relief anyway but now with
impeachment out of the way
no more excuses it's time to get coveted
relief done now
i am already to be very clear i think
joe biden's
been doing a good job so far i like how
much he's gotten done and how quickly
he's got it done joe biden did say
checks going out right away when i'm
sworn in
if we have the two senate seats
democrats have the two senate seats
we're getting close to a month and we're
still dealing with
how exactly is this uh stimulus bill
going to pass
it is increasingly and abundantly clear
that at least in the lead up
republicans aren't going to play ball
now i've said before
i think that the political risk of
voting no
on the stimulus bill is too great for
all republicans to vote no i believe
that if democrats
move forward with passing the covet
stimulus package 1.9 trillion dollars
via budget reconciliation which requires
only a simple majority meaning they can
do it with
50 senators and kamala harris's
tie-breaking boat vote i believe that if
that's the way to do it they should do
it this is too
important and it was joe biden's promise
after all
but i think you will get some
republicans who go
who go for it because many of the same
republicans
who voted guilty for trump in the second
impeachment trial
have more moderate constituencies and or
don't care so much about being seen as
sticking with the republicans and being
on the team
i think it's quite plausible mitt romney
would go for it susan collins
lisa murkowski ben sasse pat toomey a
lot of the same people who voted guilty
on saturday for donald trump
i think ultimately will come around
because they realize that this is
actually what their constituents want
so there's a new new york times article
which says
the biden agenda now with now with
impeachment out of the way the biden
agenda takes center stage
and that the order the priorities will
be passing the 1.9 trillion dollar
stimulus bill
and then doing green infrastructure and
then doing immigration
and then doing climate change and
starting to go through this list now
that's probably 18 months of stuff we
have to be realistic about how quickly
paul you know maybe a year it's not
clear but we just have to get the
coveted relief bill done
it's very clear that that is the next
step it's very clear that joe biden is
now risking
failing on a major campaign promise you
can you can argue that he already
failed in the sense that he said it
would happen right away and it's been a
month
he initially said it'd be two thousand
dollar checks then it was well it'll be
fourteen hundred to get to the total of
two thousand
okay some are defending that some are
not some are saying
it's a flip-flop regardless we're almost
a month and it's time to do it and so
the report from the new york times says
that uh this is now the priority
and that joe biden and democrats are
willing to go it alone
what has changed over the last two weeks
nothing uh joe biden
brought republicans to the white house
they wanted a plan
that was it was humiliatingly small it
was a micro plan
i would call it and it was less than
one-third the size
of what joe biden and democrats want
you're negotiating with people who are
negotiating in bad faith they're
negotiating
down down to something that's pathetic
it's peanuts for what we need
just do it it's time to get it done and
we will we will soon see uh whether joe
biden
understands the limits of so-called
unity in the limits of bipartisanship
and as jen
saki saki now i know as jen saki
said many times now bipartisanship
doesn't mean that you unite republicans
and democrats into one party democrats
say 1.9 trillion
and it includes the uh pre you know
it includes the payments that we've
outlined before in terms of payments to
individuals
payments for children business stimulus
enhanced unemployment
money for vaccine all these different
things republicans want something so
dramatically different that there's
really no way to negotiate to anything
that would make sense
the american people are overwhelmingly
on the side of joe biden and democrats
not everybody
but significant support for the 1.9
trillion dollar package so it's just
time to pass it
and this would be a
major accomplishment for joe biden my
expectation would be that as high as joe
biden's approval rating is right now
and it's the highest initial job
approval of any president since bill
clinton in 1993 over 28 years
right now this is the highest initial
approval rating of any president dating
back 28 years
i think it goes higher if joe biden is
able to get this done in the next 10
days
and if not it will start to be a drag on
him politically politics aside we need
to do it for the economy we need to do
it for people
and i remain cautiously optimistic
that in the next seven to ten days there
will be progress
we'll see what is said about it at this
week's press briefings with gensake
which of course we'll be covering on
youtube twitch and
facebook moments after being acquitted
in his second impeachment trial on
saturday with 57 senators voting to
convict but falling short
of the required 67 senators
donald trump immediately put out a
letter saying
he is not going away we've been
wondering
will trump go away or will he stick
around in politics
at least for now trump claims he is not
going to go away we will talk later
about the implications of this but he
wrote on saturday we'll look at his
letter
i want to first thank my team of
dedicated lawyers and others for their
tireless work upholding justice and
defending truth
not exactly what they did but okay
trump says my deepest thanks as well to
all of the united states senators and
members of congress
who stood proudly for the constitution
we all revere and for the sacred legal
principles at the heart of our country
well they didn't
many of them wrongly said you can't try
and or convict a former president that
is not actually the reality
constitutionally
trump goes on to say our cherished
constitutional republic was founded
on the impartial rule of law the
indispensable safeguard for our
liberties and our rights and our
freedoms
it is a sad commentary on our times that
one political party in america
is given a free pass to denigrate the
rule of law to fame law enforcement
cheer mobs excuse rioters
and transform justice into a tool of
political vengeance and persecute
blacklist cancel
and suppress all people with viewpoints
with whom that which they with whom or
which they disagree
that sounds like what the rioters did
trump saying that to criticize i guess
democrats
he goes on and says i always have and
always will be a champion for the
unwavering rule of law
the heroes of law enforcement and the
right of americans to peacefully and
honorably debate the issues of the day
without malice and without hate this has
been yet another phase of the greatest
witch hunt
in the history of our country no
president has ever gone through anything
like it
well no president has ever done the
things trump did and it continues
because our opponents cannot forget the
almost 75 million people
the highest number ever for a sitting
president who voted for us just a few
short months ago no one's forgetting
them we remember them and were horrified
by them
nobody's forgotten them i also want to
convey my gratitude to the millions of
decent hard-working law-abiding god and
country-loving citizens
who have bravely supported these
important principles in these very
difficult and challenging times
our histo historic patriotic and
beautiful movement to make america great
again
has only just begun key moment
in the months ahead i have much to share
with you
and i look forward to continuing our
incredible journey together
to achieve american greatness for all of
our people there has never been anything
like it
we have so much work ahead of us and
soon we will emerge with a vision for a
bright radiant and limitless
american future together there is
nothing we cannot accomplish
trump's saying we remain one people one
family and one glorious nation under god
and it's our responsibility to preserve
this magnificent inheritance for our
children
and for many gender and for generations
of americans to come
may god bless all of you and may god
forever bless the united sheich
no that's not true he did say united
states it was in writing so the slur
didn't apply
so most of what trump says is completely
backwards
but that's not surprising i wasn't
expecting donald trump to suddenly tell
the truth
but the matter of practical importance
here is that of
if and how trump will remain in politics
and remain a force in the republican
party not forever but at least for the
next few years
we know based on a poll from 10 days ago
64
of republican voters said it said they
would follow trump to another party 64
two thirds almost of the republican
party
is willing to leave if trump says here's
my new party come with me
and with trump putting out a statement
like this it doesn't seem as though
trump is planning to go quietly now the
questions that remain
include will trump's involvement in
republican politics
help republicans or hurt them in 2021 in
the gubernatorial races that there are
uh will trump's involvement in the
republican party help or hurt them in
2022 when they
want presumably to take back control of
the house of representatives
take back control of the senate will
trump end up criminally charged in
georgia where he's under criminal
investigation in new york
in other states and will that interfere
with donald trump's political plans and
will the republican party which for now
is still
officially speaking mostly behind donald
trump
will they sour with trump and say enough
is enough
at some point these are the questions
we don't yet know the answers but
judging from what donald trump is saying
he's going to try something in the next
few months
in terms of an involvement and we will
see how the republican party
reacts curious to know your thoughts
we'll have more coverage of this
on the david pakman show instagram page
which you can find
at david pakman show find me on
instagram at david.pacman
and we will be back right after this i
will argue
that the extremist wing of the
republican party has become too big to
fail
the radicals are too numerous
to simply go away and we'll talk about
that after the break
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
[Music]
the number one funding source for the
david pakman show
has been and continues to be membership
and membership is not just a feel-good
thing you get access to the world famous
bonus show every single day
just for members as well as commercial
free audio
and video feeds of the show day in
and day out you can sign up for
membership very very quickly
at joinpackman.com that's join
pakman.com
if the normal prices strike you as high
by
all means use the coupon code better21
all one word all lowercase become a
member today
[Music]
welcome back to the david pakman show
one of the questions we keep asking is
whether the future of the republican
party is in mitt romney is it in lindsey
graham
or is it in marjorie taylor green uh
mitt romney being
at this point anyway an anti-trump
republican lindsey graham
being a formerly anti-trump republican
who now is on the trump side and seems
to like golfing with trump and being in
the good graces
of what was then a current and now
former president or marjorie taylor
greene
who exists as an elected official
only because of trump and came to power
by riding
the full-on q anon trumpian wing of the
republican party
and part of it as i've said before
depends on what donald trump's presence
or lack thereof
ends up being meaning what does trump
decide to do based on his letter that we
looked at earlier today
it seems donald trump is planning to at
least try to remain involved in the
republican party and american politics
for the time being but there's another
factor
here which is the electorate the
republican electorate because remember
that
without a wacky republican electorate
trump's candidacy in 2016 goes nowhere
if trump ran in the democratic primary
he would have gotten
nowhere because democratic primary
voters would never have been bamboozled
into making donald trump the nominee so
one of the things that 2016 showed us
was that the electorate matters and that
the electorates are dramatically
different in the republican party
and the democratic party ronald
brownstein wrote a very interesting
op-ed for cnn where he
asks whether the extremist wing of the
republican party
may be too big to fail and there are
certain numbers
that tell us that yes there are way too
many
completely radicalized extreme
republicans
for them to be relegated to political
obscurity and irrelevance maybe even
if donald trump goes quietly into the
night and opt out of american politics
which again for now it doesn't seem like
he's looking to do
and as brownstein points out in this
article uh
the american enterprise institute a
right-wing think tank did a poll
and found that nearly a third of
republicans
embrace the convoluted q anon conspiracy
theory
that marjorie taylor greene has been
espousing that trump is defending the
country
against this sort of uh cabal
of child sex traffickers a third of
republicans believe that
one-sixth to one-fifth of republicans
have praised the january sixth riots in
polling from quinnipiac
55 percent of republicans agree that
quote we may have to use
force to save the american way of life
four in ten agree with the phrase if
elected leaders will not protect america
the people must do it themselves even if
it requires taking violent actions
vanderbilt university did a study and
found that
51 percent of republicans agree with the
statement that quote we may have to use
force to save the traditional american
way of life
four in ten uh back the idea
that a time will come when patriotic
americans have to take the law
into their own hands and in the american
enterprise institute poll
half of republicans said that the attack
on january 6
was engineered not by trumpists but by
antifa these aren't fringes
when so many people believe this stuff
these aren't
five seven eleven percent beliefs in the
republican party
so yes we should be afraid because if
that contingent takes over the party for
the long term it's a dystopian nightmare
now i think it bears repeating that
trump didn't create
most of this these extremists have been
around in american politics for a long
time
they just didn't always vote they
weren't always
public about their beliefs and they
didn't have a candidate
that coalesced them and brought them out
and that's what's so dangerous about
what's going on right now
so the best scenario is that the party
is split
the romneys have to fight the lindsey
grahams and the q anon
people and they all end up so busy
fighting each other
that they end up unable to stop joe
biden and democrats from hopefully
getting things done now mitch mcconnell
knows that that's the risk part of mitch
mcconnell
voting not guilty on conviction on
saturday and then giving a speech saying
how donald trump is practically speaking
and morally speaking
completely responsible for the riots
part of this is mitch mcconnell
desperate to figure out a way to
not be tied up in fighting so that he
can get back to
what he's an expert in and i say that
not joking he's really an expert in
obstructing democrats from getting
anything done
the best case scenario is that they end
up infighting
and aren't able to obstruct the worst
case scenario is really bad
uh and it includes that they are able to
obstruct
and these trumpian clowns the the q anon
types
uh continue getting elected in the
future and
um that gets me really to the next thing
i want to talk about which is that
this is a problem that is much bigger
than one insurrection the insurrection
is a lens
it's a it's a glass it's a not really a
mirror but in a sense it's a mirror
it's a one-way mirror that lets us look
at the bigger problem of
radicalization so i want to talk about
that next
um there's a really great article in
politico that i encourage you to read
the article is by zach stanton and it's
called
the problem isn't just one insurrection
it's mass radicalization and
in this article zach writes that quote
experts say the attack meaning january 6
riot
is hugely worrying for reasons beyond
what the senate is debating
unlike other recent spasms of american
violence
this was not the work of a lone wolf nor
of a small cell of radicals the pathway
to an attempted government overthrow
unfolded in public
out loud on the internet in a process
that experts call mass
radicalization we've been talking about
how do you mass deprogram
people zack stanton is accurately
talking about
how there has been a mass radicalization
that has taken place
i would argue that trump winning the
republican primary
was already an example of that back in
2016 about the degree to which the
republican party had been
de-intellectualized and mass radicalized
as zac goes on to say the protest was
largely just a tip of the iceberg no one
knows how many americans tens of
thousands more
would willingly have joined them if
they'd been in washington that day
it's a new challenge for america and a
serious one at times and places when
large groups of people
have been inspired to embrace violence
it often leads to long-term
unrest if not outright civil war and
right now experts think it's happening
faster than ever
we talked about this almost verbatim
michael jensen
an expert on extremism said historically
mass radicalization took time but that's
not our reality anymore
jensen's research has found that over
the roughly 15 past years
the average time span of radicalization
in the u.s has shrunk
from 18 months to seven months largely
because of how our lives have shifted
online
this research goes to exactly what i
fear when i get a phone call from
someone who says my cousin my friend my
girlfriend
in some cases have been radicalized
merely by the videos recommended on
youtube
and the things shared by their crazy
aunts and uncles on facebook
and in the past it used to take longer
to have such a shift in ideology it's
now happening really really quickly
and one of the real questions is
the radicalization is happening faster
and faster the deprogramming
i don't know that can really happen any
faster and i've said before
this shift in the right started
i would argue with the reagan era in the
80s
uh welfare queens oh we're regulated
relatively benign compared to the things
we're seeing now
that was the start we're talking about a
40-year radicalization process
societally individually now
the process is down to seven months for
many individuals how do you undo that
and it's something we've been studying
and thinking about
for a very long time uh we are still
seeing i mean listen you know
at the micro level i still see trump
2020 flags it's 2021 it's over
uh the trump 2020 flags are are still
flying
and uh you could even argue in a sense
that these are kind of
new confederate flags more and more of
society considers
confederate flags to be unacceptable so
now there's this new
item to represent the ideology in some
way
uh it's sort of like it's almost a dog
whistle in a sense it's like when we
hear
thugs used by certain folks to trigger
the idea of
black men and the racialization of that
word
these are the the trump 2020 flag in
2021 has almost become a defiant code
in some sense and until we really deal
with
i mean listen how we need to deal with
education
we need to deal with culture we need to
deal with the sources of misinformation
things really aren't going to change
until we do that 40 percent of the
country
still believes that the election was
stolen uh
at uh and the the percentage of
republicans
is higher um so there is a real
i mean it's an information war and i
fear that truth is losing the
information war and
we've also talked about the
psychological aspects magical thinking
war-like mentality
we're going to take losses in war we
have to do things in war that we
wouldn't ordinarily do
during peace times these are the sort of
ideologies and ideas that are infecting
many of these people and uh this is
you know the religious fundamentalism
yes
what we are seeing with trumpism is a
pseudo-religious fundamentalism where
they do see trump as the leader as in
some senses a religious figure almost
a deity pseudo deity some might just
call them
a a uh an emotional leader
a spiritual leader of some kind the
common theme
of all of these different things is
authoritarianism
it's accomplished with a very similar
trajectory
fear which donald trump started in
citing in others in 2015 and even
earlier talking about china
immigrants etc fear democrats even you
should fear them
then indoctrination into a more
authoritarian
set of solutions for those fears that
you've generated
and then of course i alone can fix it
trump claiming that literally during his
campaign
telling you you can't even believe what
you're being told elsewhere i'm the only
person who tells you the truth maybe
newsmax and oan tell you the truth as
well
all of those elements are here and
um this is unfortunately yes
the fact that trump was able to coalesce
enough people to do what they did on
january 6th
horrible he got impeached over it it's
not insignificant it's not trivial
but the mass radicalization that led to
that being possible over a lie that the
election was stolen
should raise many many red flags
and it's certainly uh it certainly has
we're going to continue talking about it
as we go forward we'll take a quick
break and be back after this
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show is audience
supported media and you can contribute
any amount you want on patreon as little
as one dollar per month
plus you can get the daily bonus show
world famous at this point
and the daily commercial free tv show
by making those pledges at patreon.com
slash david pakman show this is audience
supported media we depend on the support
of our viewers and listeners
whether you listen to the podcast watch
on youtube or watch us
on tv or even listen on the radio
patreon.com
slash david pakman show
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
in the late phases of donald trump's
second impeachment trial in which he was
acquitted over the weekend
details emerged about an absolutely
off-the-wall
phone call between donald trump and
house minority leader kevin mccarthy
which culminated with mccarthy
screaming at trump who the f do you
think you're talking to which is not
typically the way people talk to
presidents particularly when the
president is
of the same party both of the republican
party uh the call happened on january
6th
and the reason that mccarthy was on the
phone with donald trump in the first
place
was that he was begging trump to call
off the rioters explaining to trump
these are your supporters this is
terrible
call them off tell them to go home and
mccarthy
implored trump explaining the rioters
were breaking into his own office
through windows
and reportedly what set kevin mccarthy
off
was when donald trump continuing to
refuse to call them off
said well kevin i guess these people are
more upset about the election than you
are
that set mccarthy off into a tirade who
then said
who the f do you think you're talking to
now
layer one is that this is another
cartoonishly childish data point in the
trump presidency
trump unhinged ignorant absurd as a
participant in the
american political system but the bigger
takeaway is about the january 6th riot
because this call confirms that donald
trump obviously wasn't opposed to the
rioting we already knew that
but he also wasn't just an uninvolved
observer
who may have liked it he was being told
as the president of the united states
this is what these rioters are doing
these are your supporters
and he was pleased when he says to
mccarthy
call them off now these people they're
more upset about the election
results than you are that's a comment
that's supportive of the rioters trump
believes the writers are acting
correctly in relation to
uh what donald trump feels happened in
the election which is the big lie that
he repeated endlessly that it was stolen
and he really won
trump's mindset was call them off why
would i call them off they're angry for
the right reasons they're doing the
right things
and then of course hours later far too
late to have any impact
trump put out that pre-recorded uh video
half-heartedly saying it's time to go
home peacefully
but we love you and you're great people
and you're right to be upset but
it's time to go home now this all took
place
in the midst of what mike pence uh when
mike pence
was in physical danger at the capitol on
january 6th and of course
trump knew about that and yet still went
on twitter and denounced mike pence
remember when trump tweeted we have to
now go
into a deleted tweet archive to get
these because trump's twitter account is
banned
trump saying mike pence didn't have the
courage to do i'm sorry tru
yes trump said pence didn't have the
courage to do what should have been done
to protect our country
and our constitution giving states a
chance to certify
a corrected set of facts not the
fraudulent or inaccurate ones
which they were asked to previously
certify usa demands the truth
when trump sent that at that point
trump knew pence was in danger and still
tweeted that
now once again kevin mccarthy is no
angel
in this kevin mccarthy is still merely
an amoral political opportunist how do
we know that
because just weeks after this call where
he said to trump
who the f do you think you're talking to
kevin mccarthy went down
and did his pilgrimage to florida at
trump's mar-a-lago
met with trump to recruit trump's help
in getting the house of representatives
back in 2022.
mccarthy learned nothing despite
everything that happened on january 6
flying down to beg trump for help
in the next election mccarthy still
standing by trump
and so these people deserve to be voted
out it's all just
at every point it's just how am i
affected by this
on january 6th protesters pro-trump
writers
were breaking into kevin mccarthy's
office so mccarthy said to trump you got
to stop this
and then trump didn't and so mccarthy
was furious it's just how does it affect
mccarthy
and then two weeks past that trump is
gone
democrats have the white house democrats
have the senate democrats have the house
and mccarthy wants to win it back well
if trump can help i'll fly down and
uh do my pilgrimage uh pray at the altar
of trump
down in muralago these people are
pathetic they deserve to keep losing but
it's up to us to make sure that they do
we are very quickly seeing a sort of
fork in the republican party
where some republicans are doubling down
on trump people like lindsey graham
who says he's headed down to play golf
with trump in the next week
kevin mccarthy who we just spoke about
who despite a uh
angry phone confrontation with trump on
january 6th
flew down to florida to recruit trump's
help in winning the house back in 2022
you've got those
people um but then you have other
republicans
who are sometimes overtly sometimes a
little more
covertly distancing from donald trump
mitch mcconnell was an incredible
example of this
in his speech moments after the
acquittal of donald trump
in his second impeachment trial this
weekend which we already discussed
another interesting one is republican
nikki haley
haley was the governor of south carolina
she later was donald trump's ambassador
to the united nations
she's completely abandoning donald trump
now and
she says trump quote let us down and
that
we quote shouldn't have followed him
this is arguably the most direct and
forceful rebuke of trump
from strictly political figures that
worked for trump we've seen lots of
rebukes
from secretaries and folks who had more
concrete roles trump's former secretary
of state
trump's former secretary of defense
trump's former
national security adviser john bolton
but
this is different when it's nikki haley
nikki haley's interview with politico
was published going into this weekend
and it's quite stunning she pulls no
punches
let's look at some quotes some of these
are from different parts of the
interview
she says quote he's not going to run for
federal office again
i don't think he's going to be in the
picture i don't think he can
he's fallen so far she says we need to
acknowledge he let us down
he went down a path he shouldn't have
and we shouldn't have followed him and
we shouldn't have listened to him
and we can't let that ever happen again
when i tell you i'm angry it's an
understatement mike
pence has been nothing but loyal to that
man
he's been nothing but a good friend of
that man i am so disappointed in the
fact
that despite the loyalty and friendship
he had with mike pence
that he would do that to him like i'm
disgusted by it
and lastly nikki haley saying i think
he's going to find himself further and
further
isolated i think his business is
suffering at this point
i think he's lost any sort of political
viability he was going to have
i think he's lost his social media which
meant the world to him i mean
i think he's lost the things that really
could
have kept him moving now i want to
repeat once again
this is really important about our
analysis
of what nikki haley and others have been
saying
these quotes aren't about realizing
nikki haley she gets it now
she gets she really gets it not at all
these
people are responsible for trump in
various ways
first of all in general republicans for
decades
radicalized the party more and more so
that trump was then able to run and win
in 2016 never would have been able to
win a democratic primary
but they also worked for him despite
knowing this
and this has always been trump nikki
went
and was ambassador to the united nations
for trump despite all the things we knew
about trump
so this is not an analysis of people
having an awakening and all of that
stuff
and these are good republicans this is a
story about
a republican party that is currently
pulling itself apart
or maybe is going to pull itself apart
some newcomers are riding the trump
wave marjorie taylor green lauren
beaubert madison cawthorne and others
some long-timers are just sticking with
trump like
lindsey graham some long-timers
seem to be distancing from trump like
mitch mcconnell and others
and then you've got people that were
never really with trump
mitt romney okay yeah he thought maybe
he could be trump's secretary of state
he went and had
turtle soup and frog's legs with trump
early on
but has basically a distance from trump
uh
years and years ago nikki haley wants a
continued political career
she's young she's only 49 compared to
some of these guys in their 70s and 80s
she wants to wash herself of the stink
of trump so now she's going through this
process
and what we're learning here is quite
simply
they knew all along what trump was
they merely pretended not to know
when trump was their ride to notoriety
or a position of power or a position of
prestige
they are even more immoral than we
thought because they weren't
even tricked by trump if they were
really tricked we could say
they're dumb but they're less immoral
they weren't tricked they looked away
deliberately
they knew all along what it was and they
want i mean look at chris christie
remember chris christie denouncing trump
endlessly during the primary in which he
ran
and lindsey graham too by the way then
standing behind trump figuratively and
literally remember the video of chris
christie standing behind trump
looking like he ate a bad oyster um and
saying yeah trump trump i'm with trump
and then eventually chris christie
starting to make a little more sense on
trump over the last six months
or so he knew all along it was just a
calculation how much power can i grab
by attaching myself uh to what was then
the rising star of trump they all knew
all along and none of them deserved to
be forgiven
but from a practical perspective it does
raise questions about the future of the
republican party which we will continue
to talk about
i got a very interesting email a
voicemail rather
about 2024 you can call my
voicemail number any time of day and
many of you
do the number of voicemails we get in
the middle of the night
stunning uh here's one about 2024 2192
david p
is the number hi david um this is
aerosynthetic shannon i'm calling from
towns michigan
and i was wondering um
the entire trump impeachment scenario
was going on
yes what do you think it means for this
country that
all the evidence that was shown the the
footage of the riot and the breaking of
the capital
and somehow he was still acquitted like
what does that say about this country
um does it worry you um because i'm
really afraid like if he can get away
with something like that
what are we going to do in 2024 when
like a trump junior runs
into office i'm terrified what do you
think it says about
this country and where are we going
thanks yeah
one of the most uh disgusting
i guess we have to call them realities
that we have to accept
uh is that when you look at the
republican vote
to acquit in the senate and then you
look at trump's letter saying
i'm sticking around and we've got a lot
of stuff planned for the next few months
and you see that 64 of republicans in a
recent poll
70 percent of republicans in another
recent poll say
if trump created his own party i would
leave the gop
and join the trump party what you
can you have no choice but to accept
that a trump-like figure could indeed
win again in 2024. now the hope
is that if there's a split between
trump and the republican party that
they do damage to each other and you
could have
a sort of cannibalistic effect where
trump takes some of the republican party
trump or a trumpian candidate maybe
trump jr maybe
ivanka maybe marjorie taylor green who
knows they
run and they take a bunch of the vote
and then you've got the republican vote
which is damaged
and then you end up with a situation uh
like the ross pro
situation of the early 90s with a
democrat winning
that that's the ideal scenario now there
are people who will look at that and say
you know the math could work out
differently
and i understand that um but
if 64 of the country is willing to
follow trump
we all have to recognize that that is
exactly the concern with not
ridding ourselves of this problem right
away
and how could we when tens of millions
of people continue to support it so yeah
the caller is absolutely right
in her concern we have a great bonus
show today we are going to talk about
you know i get emails all the time from
people
from from the trolls david why won't you
ever talk about what's going on with
andrew cuomo in new york
because andrew cuomo doesn't seem to be
managing a lot of things correctly and
there's a lot of things coming out
we've been covering it from the
beginning and we will again cover
how the covet 19 story is getting even
worse for democratic new york governor
andrew cuomo that's on today's
bonus show also on the bonus show the
boeing 737 max
is flying again and it's very quietly
flying again
and we're going to talk about how
airlines have brought it back
because it has been cleared but they're
not advertising
it and it's obvious why lots of people
still aren't interested if they are
going back to flying at this point
during the pandemic
they're not interested in flying on the
737 max but it is back and i'm going to
i have a kind of a personal story about
this myself we will also talk about how
the supreme court has stayed
the execution of an alabama inb inmate
who has requested a pastor's presence
the details are very interesting and we
will discuss
that and more on today's bonus show
get instant access by becoming a member
at joinpakman.com you can use the coupon
code
if you so please to get a discount the
coupon code is better21
you can also get instant access to the
bonus show by becoming a patron
at patreon.com davidpakmanshow
i will see you on the bonus show sadly
if you don't have access to the bonus
show
uh we will meet again tomorrow see you
then
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors
unbiased news is a myth ground news is a
news
comparison platform that empowers you to
see how the political biases of
different sources
are influencing the news you read
download the ground news app for free
at davidpakman.com ground